good morning John people keep asking me
this question they say Hank how do you
feel about the end of manned exploration
of space with the with the final launch
of the space shuttle to those people I
say how did you feel when sitcoms ended
with the last episode of Seinfeld
actually I think I may have stumbled
onto a pretty good metaphor he Seinfeld
like the Space Shuttle was a
long-running and critically acclaimed
program it may have just like the Space
Shuttle program been the best program of
its time it was revolutionary it changed
everything but everything has a
beginning and everything has an end and
now there are new revolutionary sitcoms
like 30 rock the office and barks and
brat Seinfeld had to step aside and as
much as it pains me to say it much was
happening to the space shuttle it's time
is done the question is what is our 30
rock here turns out I'm not the ideal
person to answer these questions cuz you
know I I don't work at NASA luckily
these people do yes I got to ask some
questions of people at NASA via video
including Charlie Bolden the guy who is
in charge of NASA first question how are
we gonna get this space astronauts to
the space station without the space
shuttle the same way we have been
getting there almost entirely since the
Columbia accident we're gonna take them
all the way to Russia down to Kazakhstan
and they will launch out of Baikonur
cosmodrome in kazakhstan aboard a Soyuz
spacecraft so I think we can all agree
that that's not particularly ideal the
question becomes what we're using the
Soyuz capsule now and we will be for the
foreseeable future but what's the next
step and for the answer that question
okay this is so cool I'm going to kick
it over to Bobby Braun NASA's Chief
Technologist we're going to have a whole
host of American vehicles traveling to
space with American crews and the best
part about that is that those systems
are being designed today by companies
all around the country I can't tell you
exactly what system is going to fly
because it's it's somewhat of a
competition it's somewhat of a race
among these American companies but I am
looking forward to seeing their their
vehicles in flight so with the private
sector and Russia taking care of getting
to low-earth orbit into the space
station and stuff what what does NASA's
focus become NASA is going to turn its
attention to getting out into deep space
to going places that we frankly haven't
been to before that is the stuff that
gets me going Bobby Braun and
me wrong I love low orbit low orbit is
great it is fantastic laboratories where
we need to be to learn about space and
its effects on people the question is
how do we get to those new destinations
hey I'll tell you what the first thing I
want is faster rockets when you talk
about trying to get some awesome back
into things we've got to get some
awesome into our ability to get from
point A to point B in space if we really
want to get beyond low-earth orbit and
do some exploring we're going to need a
better faster way more powerful engines
rocket engines to get us further out
into the solar system that last fella
was Mike Massimino an astronaut who
coincidentally completely coincidentally
is speaking at VidCon about social media
and outer space I suppose I have a hard
time expressing how excited I am about
these things or even understanding why
I'm so excited about it we're just now
starting to poke our nose out of this
pond this sphere that we live on it
created us we were built for it but our
instinct we can't deny this push for
awesome draws us out exploration of the
solar system isn't something that you
measure in like fiscal quarters it's
something that takes decades these and
generations and that's one of the most
beautiful things about it we're not
doing this just for us body of work the
body of science necessary for this
undertaking is is massive but we do
undertake it because while we were built
for this earth we were also built to
explore we're a slave to the awesome we
must do it NASA's manned space
exploration program might end up being
one of our generations most significant
legacies for mankind a beginning and a
continuation of a great human endeavor
and for a final word I give you lori
Garver NASA's deputy administrator we
are very excited about the future at
NASA we're all about increasing the
awesome Don I'll see you on Friday